hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll and today we're going to be
talking about heredity this is of course
a very old idea the idea that there's
something inside us some properties some
features that get passed down through
the generations
so we inherited something from our
ancestors and we send something down to
our descendants back in the day there
used to be the thought that royal blood
was handed down that the right to be the
king or the queen or the Emperor
depended on who your parents were I
suppose there's still countries in which
that is the case but we know a lot more
about how heredity really works now than
we used to we know that all of our cells
have a little molecule in them called
DNA and that DNA is a little code it's a
chain of letters a G C T that the
arrangement of those letters tells us
what makes up who we are or at least
there's a simplistic version of it where
you think of DNA is kind of like a
blueprint that if you knew what the DNA
was you could predict exactly what the
organism was going to be maybe even you
know what kind of food they would like
or what kind of occupation they would
have later in life today we know it's a
little bit more complicated than that
there's more going on than just our DNA
to make up who we are not only nature
versus nurture but even the nature part
is very complicated
there's epigenetics and development
factors there's mitochondrial DNA
there's the expression of different
parts of the genes that we have and so
we're in a very very rapid state of
evolution as it were in terms of how we
think about how heredity works these
days you can get your genome sequenced
you can send it into a company pay some
money and they'll tell you something
about your genetic heritage on the
horizon we see the ability to edit genes
we can do it in some ways now and the
ability to do that for human beings
probably is not very far away so it's
natural to imagine you know can we
design what the next generation of human
beings is going to be like we design the
animals and plants that make up the rest
of our ecosystem these are important
questions as well as fascinating ones so
we have
today Carl Zimmer as our guest carl is
one of the very best science writers
working out there he's been working and
writing about this area of genetics and
heredity and DNA for a very long time
you may know Carl through his blogging
or his Twitter account his New York
Times column where you may have heard
him on NPR now Carl has a major new book
out called she has her mother's laugh
the pow'rs perversions and potential of
heredity it's a door stopper it's a big
one but it's full of fascinating
individual human stories as well as the
deep science behind what we know about
heredity so we're gonna talk about how I
read 'ti works what we do and don't know
about it and most importantly where the
new knowledge that we're gaining
everyday might take us
it seems very plausible that what we're
learning these days might dramatically
change how we think about being human
beings so let's go
[Music]
Carl Zimmer welcome to the mindscape
podcast it's great to talk to you so now
we've known each other virtually least
online you know since the early Halcyon
salad days of the blogging world right
it didn't it's not how you got to know
you reading your blog and you read mine
absolutely yeah back when blogs were the
future look yes now we're in the future
and no one writes blogs anymore they
delivered us here exactly the future is
a journey you know that's and we've been
through the future now we're in the post
future so I couldn't help you've written
this gigantic Magisterial book about
heredity inheritance she has her
mother's laugh and the subtitle of
course the power perversions and
potential of heredity and while reading
it I can't help but think as a physicist
you know my goodness how lucky I am that
what I do for a living doesn't really
matter to people's lives this is a kind
of science that everyone has feelings
about right do you does that come
through in your work oh I think that
everybody clings to heredity in a
profound way and I see that when I give
talks about my book I mean I have
learned to keep my prepared remarks
fairly short because people just have
tons of questions and and the questions
come from the fact that we use heredity
to define who we are and also what is
our connection both to the past and to
the future I mean you can't ask for
anything more intimate than that yeah so
the future in terms of our children our
descendants you mean sure absolutely and
and also like what if we tamper with the
heredity of other species and you know
then what what is what is left after
we're gone well you know heredity will
carry on those sorts of changes into the
future so I think you know everyone who
is involved in this conversation right
now knows a little bit right you know
we're not entering and we're not telling
people something that they've never
heard before that there's something
called DNA in our cells and
carries some information so let's try to
remember what it was like before we knew
that right people still had an idea of
inheritance and heredity and things
being passed down through the blood even
before Darwin and Mendel came along
right I mean it's kind of hard to
reconstruct the way people fought in the
past especially when they didn't use the
concepts and the words that we use today
and yet you know we can we can start to
get some clues about about it just by
looking back and and trying to piece
together you know for example there were
ideas about blood as you say you know we
some still use the word blood to talk
about you know what we really mean by
genes you know there's blue blood for
example you know like blue blood is
something that is like well you come
from a blue blood family in other words
somehow like that is inherited down
through the generations you're sort of
status I mean the irony is of course
that the phrase actually comes from a
particular time in a particular place it
was in Spain in the 1500s when people in
Spain were trying to distinguish
themselves from Jews and Muslims so so
this is where and this is where the
whole issue of race comes from I mean
literally the word race starts to be
used in Spain in this way and so you
know they were talking what what century
said 1500s fourteen hundreds and into
fifteen hundreds and the so the idea
with blue blood was that if you were you
know racially pure then someone could
see your veins through your translucent
skin and so you know you can kind of get
these ideas about how in Western society
there were these ways in which we
started to define ourselves as as being
sort of made up of something that was
being passed down through the
generations but you know really you know
and then it wasn't until the 1800s that
people like Charles Darwin actually like
frame
as a scientific question like okay
there's something something molecular
that is being passed down through the
generations and explains why people have
these traits that seem to run in
families so what is it so yeah I mean
Darwin wouldn't have said the word
molecular right but well we know what
you mean there is something that is
being given from parents to children
what did but without genes without DNA
or anything like that with this basic
idea that we inherit from our mothers
and our fathers did anyone ever wonder
about the fact that why aren't we always
just exactly halfway in between our
mothers and our fathers in every trait
there clearly seem to be variations
around that the people in pre Mendel and
DNA worried about this fact
yeah they I mean they could see for
themselves that these patterns of
heredity were not simple
they really puzzled over them Mendel was
just in a long line of people who are
scratching their heads and you know
these were plant breeders these were
animal breeders in the 1700s someone
named Bakewell in England became
legendary because he created a new breed
of sheep and he did it by carefully
breeding different kinds of sheep
together and and coming up with these
rules of his own for how to breed them
and it was an incredible accomplishment
you know because you know people would
breed animals and you know like the air
offspring would be all sort of a mess
they would be like me you know all this
variation when you know if you're
breeding animals you all you want them
all to be the same you know if you want
a particular kind of meat from an animal
you want them all to have that same
taste you want to kind of wool want the
same wall so it was a huge puzzle and
struggle and and the stakes were
enormous I mean you know by the 1700's
and 1800's countries were actually
looking at breeding in other words
heredity as part of their national
wealth you know if you could breed new
crops and new livestock you are going to
make your country rich
I love the practicality of it it reminds
me of you know how thermodynamics which
can be a very abstract and theoretical
subject arose from trying to get better
steam engines right is you know this
this is definitely an era where there is
a give-and-take between people with
boots on the ground trying to make
better products and trying to understand
the world better as scientists yeah it
is interesting I mean because you know
we assume that everybody must have
thought about heredity the way we do and
wondered about it the way we do five
hundred years ago or a thousand years
ago but they just didn't and it wasn't
really until there's some practical
questions drove people to really think
carefully about this and you know the
other people in addition to breeders
were psychiatrists in the early 1800s
particularly in France and also some
extent the United States and elsewhere
psychiatrists were trying to understand
madness then they were struck by the
fact that when they would do
questionnaires for their patients their
patients often had people in their
family or more distant relatives who
also were institutionalized or you know
maybe they had you know something that
seemed like a form of madness and so
they said hmm so so is this a hereditary
disease and and if so how on earth could
this be passed down through the
generations and so Darwin actually read
a lot of Psychiatry when he was
developing his own ideas about heredity
so this connection between heredity and
intelligence and madness and thought was
there from the very very beginning yeah
a lot of the things that we're talking
about right now people were talking
about 150 or 200 years ago with just as
much loudness and passion and conflict
maybe not just as much because now we
have Twitter and they didn't have that
there so that's an amplifier that they
didn't have
yeah but they had pamphlets you know
like yeah a lot of this stuff would get
circulated and things like pamphlets
where you know you get a new pamphlet
every day like III feel like Twitter is
just an extension of the old traditions
of pamphlets
so maybe blogging is the past more than
the future
I don't know we're podcasting fits in
though so then we did get to genetics
right too real genetics to Mendel Mendel
by the way I have to always say this I
went to an Augustinian university
Villanova and Augustinians have a slight
inferiority complex compared to the
Jesuits who are wonderfully
intellectually had this wonderful
intellectual tradition but we have two
really important augustinians in history
one was Gregor Mendel and the other was
Martin Luther so they weren't always you
know the best Catholics but they did
affect the world in an important way so
Mendel among other things he helped sort
of pinpoint this discreteness right of
heredity that there could be like you
get this feature or you don't so there
must be somehow it wasn't just a
blending of your two parents there was
some piece of information a quantum of
physicists would call it this being
handed down through the generations
right Mendel didn't call them genes
sometimes the terms he used get
translated as factors so there would be
some kind of factor that was in a plant
and there was an almost mathematical
beauty to how these factors combined in
new offspring and then produced a trait
so just what you know an example that
people may recall from high school is
that peas can be wrinkled or they can be
smooth and if you cross two wrinkled pea
plants together there you're gonna get
nothing but wrinkled Peas if you cross
two smooth peas together you might get
nothing but smooth peas and then the
next generation after that smooth peas
and smooth speeds forever on the other
hand if you cross a smooth pea and a
smooth pea together you might be
surprised to suddenly have
a quarter of the peas being wrinkled and
and so the fact is that these that
wrinkled factor you can hide because
it's what we would now call
well actually Mendel called two
recessive so yeah so so that was the
first recognition that that there was a
circus there was a sort of thinking
about heredity when these two kind of
distinct parts the the invisible factors
that get carried on through the
generations and then sort of what you
see the what scientists called the
phenotype and then we started finally
figuring it out we're moving quickly
through the history here so when I get
to the modern world but it was until
20th century that we were able to
identify these genes as being carried by
this wonderful molecule the DNA and
Watson and Crick etc and by that time
correct me if I'm wrong but there was
already this new synthesis of genetics
and evolutionary biology natural
selection darwin and so the DNA was just
sort of figuring out not just but it was
figuring out what the mechanism of that
was yeah well that's a beautiful
distillation of like 80 years of really
rough science yes exactly yeah you know
people had known about DNA really this
is since the 1800s but they were kind of
like hey what is this weird stuff and so
as to make just make that very clear
they knew that there was a molecule
called DNA exactly if you if you pulled
apart cells you would find different
components so you'd find some molecules
that are known as proteins that all had
a similar chemical composition and then
you would find this stuff that they
called nucleic acid and and people just
didn't really know what it was for you
know and right and actually you know
even in the mid 1900s a lot of people
thought proteins were what genes were
made of and it took some elegant
experiments to
demonstrate no actually it's really if
you transfer DNA from one microbe to
another you transfer that trait the
proteins don't matter and so then once
we figured out the structure of DNA then
all of a sudden we can get down to the
molecular details of how genes make
heredity possible in other words that
it's almost like genes are like texts
you know they're they're made up of
these units that that where they're like
letters made up from a four-letter
alphabet and we have you know over three
billion letters in our in our DNA and
change the letters or cut and paste
chunks of text and you get changes to to
us and and those changes can be passed
down if the DNA is being faithfully
copied right and so 3 billion 3 billion
base pairs right in our in the human DNA
and but we talked about only having like
20,000 genes so I I'm gonna ask
everybody started on the podcast to
explain this took me a long while to get
it right but explain the relationship
between the base pairs and the DNA and
what we call genes yeah it's it's kind
of messy but you know biology is messy
yeah so so so the the way that people
traditionally think about genes is a
stretch of DNA that encodes a protein
and so you know every every protein is
is encoded by a gene it is true although
sometimes you get proteins that are made
by combining genes together and all
sorts of stuff we don't need to get into
but in any case we have as you say
20,000 of these protein coding genes and
they only make up about 1% or so 1 or 1
or 2 percent of the of our of the human
genome so then the big question is well
what's all the other stuff yes and yeah
so so some of it you know maybe 10% of
it is has functions of its own so
actually some of them are also genes
it's just that they don't go the full
process towards making proteins you have
thousands of genes we don't know how
many that actually encode RNA molecules
okay so you may be used to thinking of
RNA is part of the process to make
protein yeah good
you've got a gene made of DNA you make a
copy in RNA which is a single-stranded
version of DNA basically and then you
use that RNA as a template for building
proteins out of a different set of
molecules
Colet amino acids and that's that's true
but it turns out that sometimes our
cells will make an RNA molecule and then
that's it
and that not only that's it but that RNA
molecule has a really important job to
do so for for example in in women women
have two X chromosomes they need to keep
one of them shut off or they're gonna
basically poison themselves with too
many proteins from the X chromosome men
only have one X chromosome so there are
so there are these RNA molecules that
basically wrap around the the X
chromosome one of the X chromosomes and
women and silence it and so you know we
know that at least some of these RNA
molecules play an important job so
that's those are more genes but that
still leaves you with a lot of the rest
of the genomes so some of that DNA is
really important as kind of genetic
switches for turning on and off genes
elsewhere in the genome and then the
rest you know a lot of it is probably
what scientists would scientifically
call junk there a lot of them are dead
genes there are genes that have mutated
and just are useless now and we just
carry them along some of them are
actually descend from
viruses viruses infect our DNA and make
copies in the cells that get passed down
and just spread all over our genome and
bulk it up with all sorts of stuff that
we don't actually use so it's they also
could be codes that were injected by
aliens billions of years ago to be
activated at some point in the future
right yeah right now I haven't seen the
papers on that yet but maybe you've seen
a preprint die I'm feeling I'm giving
you Jules here Carl you should write the
paper all right I'm gonna get I'm gonna
have the scoop of the century but it's a
good reminder that you know we're not
intelligently designed the cell is kind
of a mess that has been put together
over billions of years and DNA doesn't
care that it's job is to encode genes
into proteins it does whatever it wants
to do so or whatever it needs to do to
make things function so some of the DNA
is making proteins some of it's making
RNA that will do something some of it's
just going along for the ride because it
keeps getting copied all the time right
yeah I mean it's hard to believe but the
cell is a lot sloppier than we think of
it as being you know a lot a lot of DNA
actually is used by ourselves to produce
RNA molecules and then the cell just
immediately shreds all that RNA because
those were just sort of accidental and
we're just not they didn't really have
any function so you can have junk DNA
shooting off RNA molecules but like they
don't serve any purpose so they just you
know this the cell just sort of like
manages this chaos you know by having
certain proteins that kind of go around
and say like are you are you supposed to
be here and you know if not then they
just shred them and and just recycle it
to make more RNA molecules so yeah it's
not it's it's if you really get to know
the cells intelligent design becomes
kind of laughable and so ok so we have
this idea that the coding parts there
there are parts of the DNA stretches of
DNA many many base pairs at once that
will Co
into a protein there's probably a an
informal and incorrect idea I'm sure
none of our extremely sophisticated and
well-educated mindscape listeners would
have this idea but some people might
think that there's a direct map from a
gene to a trait - you know how big our
nose are what color our hair is or how
you know charismatic we are but it's
more complicated than that right for the
most part yeah it is more complicated I
mean you know we it's good to learn
about Mendel and in high school but you
know I do think that it's going to be
important for schools to take students
beyond Mendel now that people are
getting their DNA tested by companies
like 23andme you can't really understand
those test results if you're just
relying on pea plant experiments right
you know there I mean we you know your
blood type sure it's like you know
there's one gene and and there are
different versions of the gene and that
can determine your blood type okay no
problem but but for most of the traits
that we actually really care about or
think about an even seemingly simple
ones like height they are influenced by
many many many many many different genes
and so that yeah you can't say that oh I
have do do I have the tall gene right
it's just meaningless but so we brought
ourselves up to about as you as you
infer imply the level of high school
biology you know what people sort of
remember we have a DNA we pass it along
and I think that you know even if
there's some complicated nonlinear map
from the genes in our DNA to our traits
people still had this idea that
basically there's a molecule the DNA and
from the molecule that's us that just
makes us right but we know a lot more
than that now also right I mean there's
various ways in which the thing that we
turn into is more than just what's
encoded in our DNA in any
straightforward way is that an accurate
statement yeah yeah definitely
and you know when we I mean I it's funny
you know like if if you say to someone
oh you have two eyes you must have
gotten your two eyes from your parents
they're gonna look at you funny like
what that doesn't make sense you know
and the fact is that you do get you did
get your two eyes from your parents but
when we when we talk about oh you got
this you got that from your parents
we're really more interested in the
things that are different between people
so that we can say like oh you are tall
and your great uncle Bertie was tall so
he must have gone in from him even
though of course Bertie is off to the
side whatever might be my point being
that that we just get kind of confused
about what it is that we're talking
about when we when we talk about these
these traits and the fact is that you
know you might be tall like your uncle
Bertie is tall sure partly because of
the genes you inherit but you know maybe
you and your uncle Bertie also had the
privilege of growing up in a affluent
society an affluent family
you had good diets you got medicine when
you were a kid and so that you have the
opportunity to grow to be tall because
the fact is that you know all over the
world the average height of people is
several inches higher than it was a
century ago and that's not because we
are now inheriting a different set of
genes it's just that in the in that
respect the world got to be a better
place and so so you have to sort of take
into account the the combined influences
of genes and environment or actually as
Shakespeare once called it nature and
nurture we will get there but I think
that even at the level of nature even at
level of our inheritance our genetic
inheritance I you know I'm learning
about from your book among other places
how
complicated that is for example the idea
of mitochondrial DNA right we have these
little sort of genetic stowaways in
every single one of our cells and we
hand them down to subsequent generations
that's right that's right so yeah even
if you just limit yourself to genes
heredity can be a lot more complicated
and strange than we learned about so
mitochondria we have dozens or hundreds
of them in every cell and we depend on
them for our survival they're the little
factories that generate fuel for our
cell you know using oxygen and various
nutrients to build to build fuel that we
then burn they do lots of other stuff
too so we rate the cell yeah absolutely
and the weird thing about them well
several weird things one is that they've
got their own DNA in them that's that's
aside from the DNA that's tucked away in
the nucleus so they've all got their own
DNA and if you look at a cell you can
actually watch mitochondria divide on
their own and they make new copies of
their own DNA for those new daughter
cells and you might say like whoa that
doesn't make sense that sounds like
bacteria and I was like yeah yeah that's
what they're bacteria exactly like about
1.8 billion years ago when we were
single-celled the ancestors of
mitochondria somehow ended up inside of
ourselves and some maybe some kind of
symbiotic relationship kind of like you
know cleaner fish that go inside the
mouths of bigger fish and and then they
became basically permanent residence so
that they couldn't live outside of our
cells anymore and as if that wasn't
weird enough you know when I when a
sperm approaches an egg gets its
swimming furiously and it's using that
mitochondria to generate that fuel to
swim so the only way you can get to an
egg is to use as mitochondria and then
it reaches the egg and it dumps in its
chromosomes
hmm but then it also destroys its own
mitochondria it just rips them apart
so both the sperm and the egg have
separate mitochondria from dad and mom
right and the sperm do not deliver their
mitochondria into the egg lazy bastards
well it's puzzling because you know we
are when you look at our chromosomes we
are a 50/50 split between our parents
but you look at our mitochondria it's
all mom it's just all mom so
mitochondrial inheritance is not sexual
reproduction
exactly exactly it you know back to it
for some reason we we keep out one of
the parents from that process and it's
interesting because what that means is
that you know your mitochondria is is
extremely similar to your mother's and
your grandmother's and so on and so and
so on because you know for with your
chromosomes in every generation the
pairs of chromosomes they shuffle some
of their DNA together right and so they
swap pieces in this process called
meiosis and so so after several
generations you know you're either
you're you know chromosome number two
doesn't really look all that much like
your great-great great-great
grandmother's chromosome two but with
mitochondria basically the same I mean
and and so you they're really powerful
for tracing genealogy for example you
know you could see the you can say like
aha well this person has to be the child
of this woman I mean there's just no two
ways about it
and and yeah it's a it's a you know
scientists were just looking at the
basic questions about heredity or like
wow why is this why why why would the
sperm not give the mitochondria what why
is it only the mothers and now there are
some interesting theories about it I
mean one theory is that
if you have two batches of mitochondria
inside a person coming from different
people yeah they're going to not play
well together
that they're going to operate
differently and that could actually
cause problems I mean their settings
right when we when we when meiosis
happens meiosis is the splitting of this
cell into a little sexual reproduction
cell right so you know we split our
genome in half and then they're gonna
recombine with the half from the other
parent and the mitochondria kind of
aren't participating in that process so
it's you know dad's mitochondria and
moms are just they're separately and
they they might come into conflict like
you say right right and you know there
are there are there are it's interesting
you know there are we think of sort of
mom and dad's genes as you know playing
nicely in our own genome but you know
there are there are conflicts between
the genes in our parents and
evolutionary conflicts sometimes there's
conflict between our actual parents -
yeah and now think about it inside our
DNA you know you know sometimes yeah
they'll be like you know dad's genes are
maybe sort of driving kids to grow
faster because that's good for the
father's long term evolutionary benefit
the mother meanwhile if the mother is it
has to carry you know the children I
think it has to be pregnant like too
much growth is actually I can really
drain her resources and may mean that
she has fewer children over her lifetime
and so you will actually find that oh
the man's copy of a gene is turned on a
woman's copy is turned off inside the
child it's so it's like this tug-of-war
going on sure just to try just to try to
that finds a sort of optimal thing and
then sometimes you actually find there
are there are genes or pieces of DNA
that basically just totally break
Mendel's law completely and just sort of
override that sort of 50/50 kind of
split between which chromosome ends up
you know in in an egg or a sperm this
was illustrated with the discovery once
of certain kinds of flies certain
strains of flies that where they would
almost always produce daughters and I'd
like what's going on here and it turned
out that there was a gene that was
basically hijack it was sitting on the
you know on the female chromosome in in
in flies and was sort of basically
ensuring that these flights did not have
any sons because if if there were just
daughters I would spread this gene
further sort of the ultimate selfish
gene well this makes sense right I mean
we maybe make sense maybe I'm leaping
ahead too far but we have this kind of
game theoretic way of thinking about not
just the struggle to survive as
organisms but we can in the selfish gene
way of thinking think of it as the
individual genomes trying to pass
themselves down and you know mom has a
genetic set of information and so does
dad and they both want to win and in
human beings and mammals there's this
rough equilibrium that we've reached
where children are 50/50 male and female
but that's certainly not universal
across the animal kingdom is this sort
of different equilibria you could might
imagine reaching where the struggle
plays out in different ways sure and and
actually there are some animals that
adjust the ratio of their offspring just
depending on what their environment kind
of looks like so there there are birds
that you know in effect what they're
doing is looking around and saying like
I think I need a lot of daughters to
stick around and to help me raise you
know my other chicks and voila
incredibly they produce more daughters
and sons and then there are other
situations that they personally reduce
more sons than daughters you know and
then the sons fly off so yeah I mean
it's we you know we like to think about
we like to take biology and put it into
categories and try to
come up with absolutes so you know
Mendel's observations become Mendel's
law ha or males and females become these
sort of absolute categories that you
know you could never have any exception
to I mean we we keep doing that I think
we just have very you know brains that
really like categories but you know
heredity just does not work like that
yeah and you know yeah there are some
patterns that kind of repeat themselves
a lot but a lot of times those patterns
are this sort of sort of a stable
balance produced by competition that
sort of works out into this this almost
like a date aunt well I talked with
Alice dragger in Episode three of the
podcast and we talked about inter
sexuality and how the fact that the idea
there's two sexes right that's a
convenient fiction it see it's very
useful it's a good approximation but if
you're gonna try to be a little bit more
careful there's a whole bunch of stuff
in between in different ways you can be
in between and this reflects I think
that philosophically this is just a
really important point that you're
bringing up that we organize the world
we human beings for our comprehension
because it's easy for us but as we try
to be more and more accurate all those
complications going to become more and
more relevant to a better understanding
yeah and and I noticed that a lot of
times people will justify these absolute
categories by saying like well look like
this is just nature you know this is
this is biology you have to just accept
biology and I was like whoa like you
wanna talk about biology let's take a
little tour shall we and Andrew my 600
page book on inheritance I mean the fact
is that heredity itself works very
differently in a lot of different
organisms and you know the irony is is
like this is this is one reason why
Mendel was forgotten mmm actually so
this is is this one of these these
incredible ironies is that Mendel
studied Peas and he was like oh my gosh
look at this mathematical thing that's
happening and he wrote to one of his
mentor's and his mentors like
hmm that's interesting I'm not sure what
to make of this
but why don't you see if you can
replicate this you know like if if this
is what you say it is then you ought to
be able to find it in another plant
right so Mendel I guess agreed with that
anyone studied another common garden
plant and it turned out that this this
other one hawkweed I think I forget the
name now it it doesn't reproduce in the
neat sort of sexual way that peas do it
has pollen you know pollen is sort of
like the plant equivalent experiment so
they have male and female gametes and
and they have you have to have
fertilization but in these other plants
once fertilization happens the the
ovules the the eggs as it were just
basically just kick out any male DNA
they don't use it so they do meiosis you
know it within their own genes and so
base they're kind of like clones except
that they're serving their DNA with
every generation so you know like boom
like those lovely three-to-one patterns
that Mendel taught with peas they're
just not there at all right when he
looks at another species and then it's
like huh and you know you imagine if he
had picked another species that was very
neat about very you know worked like
peas did that he might have gained more
traction but no I mean he was he was
forgotten for basically 50 years it's
good to know that the deflationary role
of mentors has not changed in academia
all over the centuries that's I think
I've done that to my students sometimes
I love the idea that mitochondria is
important as they are these stowaways
that I mean they're basically living
their own lives right they're handing
down their own genetic inheritance and
it's part of what makes us who we are
and so forth are there other examples of
that I mean I know that we carry around
a whole microbiome a whole set of little
mono cellular organisms
function in us but my impression is that
we kind of build those up throughout our
lives we don't actually get those from
mom and dad well you know that is a big
question right now and and you know
there are people who are trying to
really nail that down at the moment
because you know it is true that you
pick up microbes every day you're
picking them up off your keyboard and
your doorknob and your shaking hands or
you know you're having yogurt I mean
like we're just yeah we're we're just
swimming through a microbial ocean and
are you you don't mean me in particular
you mean all of the listeners out it's
not my keyboard that is worse than
average right well I've heard things
no so so so the the thing is that we we
also know that there are lots of species
that pass down certain microbes as
faithfully as they do their own genes
and my favorite example is cockroaches
okay so you know cockroaches actually
depend on one species of bacteria to
help them to eat food because the
bacteria can actually make some of the
compounds they need for proteins out of
their food that the cockroaches don't
have the genes to do it so they totally
depend on these bacteria and in fact
they actually build special little
organs for these bacteria to live in and
the bacteria actually like embedded
inside the cockroaches own cells in this
organ and when it comes time for the
female to produce her eggs something
incredible happens some of these cells
that are carry these microbes they just
start crawling and they make their way
through the cockroaches body to the
cockroaches eggs and then they open up
and they basically deliver these
bacteria into the eggs and so after
these eggs get fertilized by a male
cockroach then the cockroach is born
with these bacteria ready to go
just like we are with our mitochondria
biology is very scary it's mind blowing
and they're you know I really you know
the the the best book on all of this is
ed Young's book I contain multitude yes
um
for me what interests me in particular
about this is to think about this as
another form of heredity another channel
of heredity it's like you've got your
own genes quote unquote but then you
have these bacteria yeah
now we don't have anything quite like
that except for mitochondria that we
know I know but right but maybe there is
something like heredity in the way that
some of our bacteria end up inside of us
you know scientists are trying to figure
out for example our human embryos
sterile when they're in the uterus like
that it the the evidence is not clear
what is clear is that as as a baby moves
through the birth canal during delivery
it gets slathered in bacteria and some
of that pipe here it goes into its gut
and and and there are certain forms of
bacteria that the mother encourages to
grow in the birth canal and not only
that but but the mother's milk contains
bacteria as well as well as bacteria
food in other words sugars that in the
milk that babies can't digest themselves
but bacteria can so so there is a debate
right now whether there might be you
know certain species that are are being
put into babies early on and sort of our
kind of define our own species that way
it's a very romantic picture you are
painting the miracle of childbirth is so
enhanced by our scientific understanding
it's really great well but it and raises
some very practical medical questions
you know cesarean sections are exploding
in countries like the United States and
so you know you so those babies are not
getting that exposure and so there's a
question of like well does
um you know can you still pick up those
species just by being handled by your
parents and other people or or does that
not getting that seating at the
beginning is that is that a problem
because you know if your microbiome then
isn't quite right when you're young I
can lead to problems throughout your
life you know your immune system may not
work properly for example is it still
thought to be true that the number of
unicellular organisms in our microbiome
is more cells than human cells in our
body actually no I heard rumors that
that had gone away that that thought
yeah yeah so you know and I and other
people have when we'd write about the
microbiome we always say like you know
your microbes outnumber your own cells
by ten to one which you know it's always
fun to say um turns out probably not to
be true it it's just it's probably more
more like one to one so we have about 37
trillion cells of our own or
quote-unquote own human cells it might
be around the same you know I don't know
30 40 million bacteria you know I don't
that doesn't count the viruses and the
fungi and all the other fun critters
that are living inside of us so you know
the final number of the full microbiome
might be higher but it's not a ten to
one thing anymore but a but a body a
biological body is a complicated open
system it's a it's a ecosystem all by
itself it's a we're a little bus that is
carrying around you know a whole world
of little critters talking to each other
and evolving and doing their own things
yes but it's not a totally random
collection of critters um you know like
the same species and the same strains
tend to turn up again and again in
people and I mean MOT your microbiome is
gonna be different than mine but but not
too differently you know and so you can
like if you look at human micro biomes
compared to like a chimpanzee
there there there gonna be a lot more
similar to each other than chimpanzees
are and it seems like there are we have
filters right you know so not everybody
gets to see it in the bus and then
there's also the idea that we're
learning more and more that just the
information in our DNA even just getting
back to the sort of genetic part of
inheritance there's more to it there's
more to how we pass information down
there's the whole story of epigenetics
and so forth
I hear that you're advocating that
people take epigenetic yoga classes so
they can pass down new things that they
learn to their children is that right
many people are saying that now I'm yeah
right right now I think you should you
know take up a genetic yoga if you like
it but don't think that your kids are
going to be better for it that we can
learn something and pass it down right
yeah that we could have an experience
that alters how our genes work and that
alteration can get passed down to future
generations that's that's the crux of
epigenetics and heredity you know and
and it's it's it's tricky and I explored
in in my book and and you know it's it's
there's definitely good evidence for it
happening in plants it's good evidence
for it happening in little teeny tiny
worms when you get to mice there's
there's some very tantalizing
experiments I mean so for example there
was one experiment where scientists
would would expose male mice to a
certain odor and then give them a shock
and then they learned us to associate
the odor with the shock and then they
took sperm from the mice and used it in
in vitro fertilization and then produced
Mouse pups and it seems like the mice in
the next generation kind of responded
oddly to that same odor
and so the claim was that somehow that
learned memory that learned association
about that smell got passed down to the
mouse pups you know and when that paper
came out the journal put Lamarck on the
cover yeah remind us who the market mr.
DeMarcus mr. Lamarck so right so so
Lamarck was a French biologist who
preceded Darwin he was most active in
the early 1800s and came up with his own
theory of evolution which depended a lot
on what's known as the inheritance of
acquired traits and so so he had a
classic example that you know giraffes
stretch their neck to reach leaves
there's some sort of nervous fluid that
causes their their necks to get a little
bit longer you can think about it at
that like like building up muscles and
then and then that then those giraffes
would pass down that longer neck to
their descendants and so then over many
generations the dress would adapt to
their environment by getting a longer
neck and so you know the claim I guess
is that well mice you know are adapting
to their environment by learning about
you know the risks that they face and
then that they're asking or inheriting
that knowledge right so that's the basic
idea and how would this work sort of at
the molecular level for the mice is it
pups you call them mice pups mice babies
or pups okay I learned something so it's
a matter of obviously the DNA are not
being altered as you as you smell
something your DNA is still your DNA but
somehow there's information being passed
down to the next generation that is not
in the DNA is somehow in the chemical
makeup of what goes into making a little
puppy yeah yeah I don't think if you
call a few common Mouse puppies at a
biology conference people
I look at you funny you think the people
will see through me and I realize I'm
not a chest there's an imposter in our
ranks as a cosmologists get them out ya
know so so so the the we know we know
that genes are attended to by lots of
molecules in the cell you know genes
just don't take care of themselves and
so there are proteins for example that
will clamp on to genes and they can
essentially shut them down there are
other places that proteins latch on to
DNA and they can switch on a gene you
can coil DNA around spools and then
basically anything that gets coiled up
any gene just can't be used to make a
protein because it's just all tucked
away and so and those changes can be
very long-lasting like when a cell
divides those same controls will in
effect be inherited by the two new cells
so that's why your skin cells when they
divide they make skin cells they don't
you know make brain cells or two cells
or something you know the good so so we
know that epigenetics really matters a
lot there's no question about that and
so the question is could these kinds of
processes you know change the way that
genes are being used and then could
those changes you know those proteins
and those coils or whatever get passed
down through the generations we don't
know yeah we the mechanism for it it's I
mean is is it's especially for mammals
it's it's kind of hard to figure out how
the mechanism would actually work and
you look at a mouse experiment I mean
though the critics of this kind of
researcher says like whoa so you're
telling me that there's this change that
that is happening in the mouse's brain
the daddy mouse is burning and and that
somehow then that is getting
communicated in to Daddy mouse's purr
and then somehow that is then making its
way through fertilization through the
development of an embryo through the
development of a brain and then somehow
that's getting plugged into it back into
the brain in the same circuits that
daddy had being altered and a lot of
scientists just say like whoa that
doesn't make any sense at all right so
this is something that's being studied
we'll try to figure it out yeah but in
the meantime there's epigenetic yoga
like you know there are literally like
psychiatrists who will help you to undo
the epigenetic trauma probably that your
grandparents passed down to you like
this has totally saturated pop culture
and I don't honestly know how it
happened because you know epigenetics is
messy and complicated and and the
language is totally inscrutable and yet
you know when I give talks like half the
questions I get after after the talks
are what about epigenetics and looks I'm
writing a book about quantum mechanics
so the idea that crazy abstract ideas
are going to be hijacked by popular
culture is not foreign to me any any
tips
well quantum epigenetic yoga might be a
best-seller right Oh dark energy in
there and we'll be buying yachts at any
moment so okay we need to we need a
trick we need to patent that idea right
now author author the book I will edit
this out the podcast so no one hears
that and steals our great idea it sounds
like though even in principle if you
handed a computer a complete list of the
six billion three billion base pairs in
our DNA the gcta
letters in our alphabet a computer with
perfect knowledge that would not be
enough to predict what the organism
would look like I mean it would be
missing the mitochondrial DNA it will be
missing all sorts of chemical signals
that could be passed down through the
body but I mean so where it sounds like
we're learning how much of the organism
is predicted by that probably a lot
right but certainly not the whole thing
yeah and in a way this this is one of
those deep questions in the history of
biology
you know how much
of an organism is basically determined
at the very beginning and how much of an
organism's end result is just the
emergence through development you know
through and and you know it's you know
as always the answer is both but it's
complicated you know in the sense that
there are a lot of things that you can
predict based on DNA those predictions
may are not like you know I can't like
predict what color shoes you're wearing
right now today based on your DNA Shawn
but I bet if I looked at your DNA I
could get a pretty good idea what your
eye color is and I might be able to you
know make make some very crude
predictions about the influence of your
genes on your height I couldn't tell you
how tall you are
because I don't know if your parents you
know fed you properly but you know I
there are things that you can predict
out of DNA but then there's this you
know that the DNA makes you know the
cells make proteins that are named
molecules from the genes and they're the
cells are talking to each other and and
they're taking in cues from the
environment cells are migrating through
the body and all sorts of all sorts of
crazy stuff is happening and and oh the
genes are responding to all of that and
that is how we end up the way we are so
yeah so you know if someone you know I
had my genome sequence I'm sure nobody
could make any predictions about me from
that yeah right I do want to that's
right I remember this from the book so
when you say you had your genome
sequenced so like you're special here
because he really had the full-blown
treatment if people do ancestry.com or
23andme or any of these things they get
a little bit of information about their
genome but they do not get a list of 3
billion ACG T's right I mean they get
some some sub knowledge of that dude do
you actually have a printout
you know all three billion base pairs in
your DNA I do not have a printout I have
a hard drug a metaphorical I was being
metaphorical yeah well well if I printed
it out it would you know fill up you
know dozens and dozens of books I mean
it would be a fun art project but you
can use a small font it's okay yeah and
it would be kind of hard to you know do
a search function on that so I prefer
prefer to have it on that hard drive
because then I can take it to scientists
and say like okay you know let's let's
play around with this data here which
just so happens to be my genome and show
me how you discover things in human
genomes by analyzing this sort of data
and it's been a fascinating experience
but it is a very different thing than
getting your DNA sequence from a place
like 23andme what 23andme or ancestry
does is they do something called
genotyping so basically they look at
maybe let's maybe a million markers a
million spots in throughout your genome
and they try to they look at say well
which a variant do you have at that
particular spot and so it's you know
it's kind of a high-level survey of your
genome but you can learn an awful lot
one of the reasons you can learn an
awful lot is because we we passed we
tend to like share similar stretches of
DNA so so if you've got you know a
string of variants all in a row chances
are that that whole segment of DNA is
identical to somebody else that has
those same variants and so you can kind
of you can infer a lot about what's in
between those markers when you get your
whole genome sequence that means that
you're trying to figure out as best as
you can every single letter in your
genome and and that with that you can
discover all sorts of deeper things
about your genome well in one of the
deeper things you could discover is that
you are susceptible or even almost
inevitably go
to have some disease that might affect
you at a certain time of your life and
so there's this question of what do we
want to know like if if you could the
the Philosopher's would come in and
instantly say the version of the
question to ask is if you could know you
were going to die exactly a certain day
would you want to know that is that
information you want some much cruder
version of that might be available
through this looking at our genomes that
information is really only available to
a small fraction of the people who get
their DNA genotype or get their genome
sequenced because the the genes that
really have a strong impact on your
health you know let's say you know we're
talking about genes that cause
Huntington's disease or genes that raise
your risk dramatically of getting early
onset Alzheimer's genes that
dramatically raise your risk of getting
certain forms of cancer
these are rare right you know natural
selection is not fond of these genes for
all these reasons so therefore they're
rare and and and so you know i when i
got my genome sequence the first part of
it was was doing it i did it as part of
a conference and i think there were like
40 people were going to this conference
who also got their genome sequenced they
weren't getting the raw data but they
were getting these interpretations from
clinical geneticists and there were like
40 of us and i if I recall correctly
maybe like five people
we're told like okay you know we're
gonna sit down with genetics counselor
and make some plans for you to talk to
your doctor because there's something
you need to know about how's your life
insurance plan looking Yeah right right
I mean for the rest of us it was like
man
no like you don't have anything really
you don't have anything that really
jumps out you know as what they would
say you know there's nothing where it's
like hey that gene that's big trouble
now you know I have plenty of genes that
have been associated with you know
raising my risk of this disease or that
by some modest amount but that doesn't
mean that I'm going to die of any of
those diseases
I mean I also have variants that lower
the risk for certain diseases too and
and so so you know and that's you know
that is going to be how most people are
going to find but that's most people are
going to find when they when they get
their DNA sequenced and it's going to be
either you know they're a lot I'm
concerned that people not make one of
two mistakes one mistake is to be like
sort of angry and irritated that they
didn't find anything in their genome you
know it's like really like my genome is
much more interesting than you're making
it out to be yes well you know like like
this isn't like a status thing like it's
not like you want to go to the doctor's
office and get terrible news you know
and like it's not like you feel like
you're you should feel happy if they say
oh you're fine see you later
and also the flip side of that is that
sometimes people will will get in these
reports or maybe do their own research
and discover they have a gene that is
associated with some diseases you know
let's just say like colon cancer and
they say oh my god that's it I'm gonna
die of colon cancer like no no no you
like think you have to you have to dig
down that extra level and say like well
what exactly did this study find you
know like do you do did find that like
people who had this variant had you know
a slightly higher risk of this disease
yeah and also like how big was the study
like if if a lot of these studies when
their preliminary it's just like a
hundred people they're tiny and you know
tiny studies are often wrong and so
there are plenty of
mutations that were thought originally
to cause diseases that we now know do
not so you know you kind of think about
all these things when you're looking at
these results and that's kind of gets
back to me and my how I feel that like
our high school grade school genetics
has just got to step up its game because
these things are not just abstractions
that you learn about in high school
never think about again people are
getting these results in in their email
INBOX
right but also isn't it isn't it maybe
an antiquated kind of worry because I
thought recently I bought new running
shoes so I went to the Nike website and
they let you actually customize your own
shoes like you know what color the front
and what logo is on the bottom and stuff
like that so within a couple generations
will have a website for doing that for
our babies right we'll just be able to
pick what different features you want
them to have edit the DNA and get
whatever baby we want I am sure that
there will P be people who are offering
that if the laws allowed you know I
don't think that you will get the babies
of your dreams I think your baby will
will just be your baby and and will be
subject to all the vagaries of
experience and biology and all the rest
of it but you know we already have all
sorts of companies out there that are
offering really dubious claims based on
looking at your DNA you know they look
at a few variants and they'll say AHA
like here's your special you know
exercise program or here's your here's
your special DNA diet or there's even a
company that called vovinam I don't know
if you've seen them know they will
recommend wine to you based on your DNA
sorry how do you spell that I actually
have to look this up what is this please
do VI n om e vine all right could be a
podcast sponsor down the road
well yeah you may not want to play this
episode
I mean when I saw a video for it I just
thought well this is this wait is this
the onion I I'm this this can't be real
but it was and you know like I mean all
these companies seem to be doing as far
as I can tell is you know looking the
scientific literature and saying like
you know oh do you know here's a variant
where people who had it tended to report
a stronger sensation for bitter tastes
and people who did like and then going
from that to saying like here take this
Pinot Noir and you know with exercise
it's a very similar thing I mean yeah
sure there are genes that are associated
with all sorts of aspects of exercise
you know the power in your muscles or
how much oxygen you take in and so on
and I'm sure that like there is a
genetic element to great athletes being
great but you know I when i got my
genome sequenced the company that gave
me that first sort of first layer of
results before i took matters into my
own hand they actually accept like your
muscles are billed for power
sorry i do not mean to laugh I was
laughing it's something completely
separate that was happening here in room
I'm sure I'm sure no it's okay Sean yeah
like I mean you you've met me and and I
I mean like anybody who has met me knows
that my muscles are not built for power
I mean it's just not the case and you
know but what they were doing is they
were just looking at this one variant
and these these limited number of
studies and not taking into account all
the other genes that influence our
muscles many of which we don't really
understand so yeah there's so I do worry
about you know letting letting folks
like that mate who run these companies
do the same thing with with you know
designing babies well tell us a little
bit though about CRISPR and the reality
of gene editing it is something that
is rushing at us very very quickly right
yeah yeah I mean I only became aware of
CRISPR maybe six years ago or something
and and I can remember thinking I mean
at first I was sort of puzzled by it
because actually CRISPR would was it's
it's natural thing what it is is it's
basically an immune system for bacteria
they make molecules that that can
essentially store information about
viruses and then use that information to
create new molecules that could zero in
on particular stretches of virus DNA and
cut it and I thought wow that's that's
cool I mean microbes never cease to
amaze me
but but then some scientists said hmm
well we could use that and we could
maybe cut whatever DNA we want and lo
and behold they could they could zero in
on particular stretches of DNA and make
cuts and then substitute in new DNA and
all of a sudden they had this very
powerful new molecular tool at their
disposal you know scientists used CRISPR
all the time now to do experiments you
know they might say like we want to know
you know which cell I'm sorry we want to
know you know which genes in a cancer
cell are essential for it to survive as
a cancer cell so they just used CRISPR
to systematically cut out every single
gene in individual cell lines and just
see which one survived as as cancer you
just couldn't do that before I mean
that's so the impact is unbelievable and
then people are starting to say like
well can we use this to alter the genes
of crops or of animals and the answer is
hell yeah and so so the next step is
well what could we do for people and one
of the things you can potentially do for
people is treat hereditary diseases so
if someone has sickle cell anemia you
take some of their
their bone marrow cells out these stem
cells are can make blood you tweak their
DNA so that they can now make hemoglobin
that they need you know the proper kind
of hemoglobin because sickle cell anemia
is caused by a misshapen kind of
hemoglobin and you put the cells back
into people and they make healthy blood
cells that's that's the hope and there
are clinical trials that could start
very soon on that and then the big
frontier the one that that you know
understandably everybody gets excited
and scared about is what if you could
use these on embryos and change genes
and embryos and then you are creating an
inherited change that will be passed
down through the generations right yeah
they're gonna do it right it's good I
mean so there's no you know III have a
kind of an extremist point of view on
this because people say people raise
this question that you just raised you
know can we genetically edit what's
going on in embryo and therefore change
what the person is gonna be like and
there's a sort of instant reluctance
right it's it's like well of course that
would be bad or at least it might be bad
we should think about it and we should
you know really be very careful but I'm
not quite sure where the reluctance
comes from other than a sort of squicky
'no sort of feeling that we're messing
with nature and what I suspect is that
some people will feel that way and some
people will not feel that way and it's
absolutely 100% gonna happen and a
hundred years from now the idea of just
making a baby by randomly picking half
of the DNA from mom and half the DNA
from dead and hoping for the best will
seem hopelessly barbaric well you know
you and I are gonna have to you know
hope that you know life extension
anti-aging drugs advanced really quickly
so that we can make a bet and see if it
pans out you know yeah
but you know I I have thought about
these scenarios a lot partly they're
just fun to think about and and it's and
and you know it's just it's it's what
science fiction writers do so well and
you know I there are a lot of questions
I have I mean I don't I I'm not as
sanguine maybe the word as you are like
in the sense that so for starters like
crisper like crisper is is indeed
revolutionary but it it's turning out to
have some some problems it because it's
it's bait it's people call it
gene-editing but it's editing that
involves shopping DNA and that is a
pretty radical thing to do to DNA and
cells don't like it I mean we the cells
actually have all sorts of defenses
against chopping up DNA because it can
lead to all sorts of damage that can
ultimately cause a cell's descendants to
become cancerous for example and not
only so you know there there are
concerns about just how safe CRISPR
would be in terms of like creating a
line of cells you'd want to put in your
body through CRISPR like you don't want
to put in cells that are going to be
more prone to cancer so that's probably
number one problem number two there's a
recent study that showed that sometimes
when scientists try to cut one
particular segment of DNA out they cut
out a long stretch that includes that
that particular target and so you might
be cutting out pieces of DNA that you
really need and maybe maybe that when
the DNA is getting repaired it gets kind
of shuffled around in ways that could be
a problem so so okay so there's the
safety issue and then then also there's
kind of like the logistics issue you
know like you
if you're saying I mean you know you're
saying like oh this is barbaric
so you're imagining a world where are
you imagining world where all say nine
billion people all get in vitro
fertilization you know I mean vitro
fertilization is a very difficult
drawn-out process right now it could get
a lot better in the future but you know
maybe not maybe there's some inherent
sort of limits to do this it's not so my
point is like course it wouldn't be
course you wouldn't have CRISPR alone
would not deliver you into that science
fiction future you'd have to have all
sorts of other advances in reproductive
technology and stem-cell research and
all the rest of it before this could
even be possible but but I have talked
to biologists who say you know we're
gonna look at we're gonna we're gonna
look at CRISPR like vaccinations in the
future right yeah so I I think I I get
absolutely the fact that it's not within
the next five years or ten years right
we will have to extend our lives if
we're gonna see this thing come true and
I'm also not sanguine in the sense I
think that it's not going to be an
unalloyed good I look at you know this
editing of our children's genomes as
some it's a technology it's like cars or
Twitter right there's gonna be good
parts about it or bad parts about it I
just think it's inevitable I just think
that it's it's like we have jumped off
of a pier into the ocean and as we fall
in we're debating should we get wet or
not and that's just not a debate that
it's very reasonable to have we should
have other debates should we swim for
Shore should we try to climb back up the
pier should we fight off the Sharks but
I think it's going to happen and you
know people are going to be trying to
alter their children's intelligence and
skin color and size of their noses and
everything and I think that we're kind
of dropping the ball a little bit on
dealing with what the implications of
that really are gonna be well I mean I
guess the question becomes you know if
people really are going to try to do
this if
they can that you know should we pass
laws to prevent that or do we have do we
put regulations in place to allow
certain uses of it for certain things
and then and then really use shifting
from a scientific question to a social
or a political one you know for example
with we're dealing with that right now
actually I mean people don't realize it
but you know genetically engineering
humans has already begun because you
know something we were talking about
mitochondria before like so so mutations
can cause mitochondria to become
defective and so women can pass down
defective mitochondria to their children
and you can get these mitochondrial
diseases which can be quite devastating
there are all sorts of different ones
that emerge from from faulty
mitochondria so some years ago people
thought well what if we were to do a
transplant an egg transplant take the
the DNA in the nucleus of an egg and put
it into a donor egg that has good
mitochondria in it obviously you take
out the nuclear DNA out of the egg donor
egg first but anyway so so basically
you're just now you have an egg that has
the mother's nuclear DNA the chromosomes
and another woman's mitochondria and
then fertilize that people call that
three parent babies which is unfortunate
but it's stuck anyway well we can debate
about what it means to be a bad but yeah
but in any case you know in the United
States that has been vant I mean you
that there's no there's no way that's
going to happen in the United States
there's no way there's going to be
research or evaluation of it forget it
that's that is dead in the water right
now and you know there was a case of a
knee of a doctor in New York who had
done some research on this who actually
went to Mexico to treat a couple who the
mother had a mitochondrial disease and
so they
ago doesn't have any laws one way or the
other about it so they did it kind of on
the you know secretly and but meanwhile
in Britain they talked about this they
vary quite explicitly I had discussions
in Parliament and they said you know
what these diseases are so devastating
and we feel that you know this
combination of mitochondria from one
women and chromosomes from another woman
we're okay with that you know we don't
think that violates sort of human
dignity and we're going to allow this to
go forward under a lot of regulation and
so there's a university in Britain that
has gotten a license they're open for
business and so they will start probably
babies will start being born soon
through this technology so you know I
wonder like what's gonna happen with
CRISPR like with a bead will it be the
American version total ban will it be
the Mexico version like it's all kind of
a you know unregulated black market or
is it going to be out in the open
carefully explicitly regulated you know
and under the guidance of government
well and I think that's a being a little
intentionally provocative here because I
think that people are there's a tendency
for people either to just sort of ask
rhetorical questions and leave them
hanging without clicked answering them
or there's this other tendency which we
in the United States love so much is
just to ban it first and ask questions
later
for something like designer babies if it
does become possible and obviously
there's enormous scientific technical
hurdle hurdles to getting there but you
know I could easily imagine that it's
banned here and so okay so someone sets
up a clinic in Mexico or the Cayman
Islands or whatever and rich people go
there and design their babies and poor
people can't do it or even if it doesn't
get banned anywhere like you alluded to
earlier there's just okay you can do it
it costs a million dollars right that's
just how much that the effort is going
to require and so that's the kind of
inequality socially that is is going to
be hard to deal with it's a little bit
it
hits home in a way you know the ability
to make sure all your children are you
know tall and beautiful that other kinds
of inequality might not I I have a
problem with the these arguments against
CRISPR based on inequality because they
all make it sound like we are living in
a paradise of equality today you know
what we're not you know like you're you
know if you're if you are concerned
about inequality like like it's time to
get started now because it's not as if
genes are the only thing that can
influence the the success of children
later in life and and so you know and
you know and this this raises do i I do
think that this also raises difficult
questions because you know if you said
okay well it's wrong to let parents use
CRISPR to make their children let's say
you know tall and beautiful or whatever
you want to dream that you could do with
CRISPR I don't think that would happen
but let's just pretend you could do that
anyway okay so what about all the other
advantages that children of wealthy
parents have that that helped them to
get ahead in life you know do we make
those illegal should SAT prep classes be
banned yeah no I think this is very real
but I still think the analogy is not
quite perfect I mean I get it and I
think that we are a terrible Society at
treating people equally right now that
that point is very very well taken but
in America at least you know people grow
up with this idea that someday no matter
where you come from you could be a
millionaire you could be president but
no one grows up with the idea that you
know twenty years from now my DNA will
be better so there's a it's a it's this
kind of obvious in-your-face difference
between people which I suspect people
will react to very viscerally I I agree
and I mean I think part of it is that
well
you know part of the problem here is
that we think of genes as being the sort
of absolute definition of who we are
it's not but but we also think about
heredity and in the sense that like
these kids will then pass down these
traits to their kids and so on and and
that really like strikes a chord I think
because like I was saying before like
heredity is is such a profound thing to
us in terms of how we define ourselves
and so to be tampering with heredity
seems like one of the great the
transgressions
and-and-and that I think colours are our
our discussion of this and you can see
this and you know then the debates
debates people have you know scientists
who developed CRISPR actually have just
in the past a few years like have a
series of international meetings so to
figure out like what what what's right
what's wrong what should we do with with
this and the overriding issue it seemed
was what is this going to do to heredity
which is so striking to me because it
really tells you where our concerns are
located and I think it's a good question
but you know on the other hand I mean I
just I don't
some people say like oh we're gonna turn
ourselves into two separate species you
know you'll have the rich people who can
afford CRISPR who will become their own
species and the poor people will become
a different species and Sir reminds me
of you know the time you hear HD wells
yes exactly that's right you know what
I'm talking about yeah that but you know
you know like but but people but like
that just people just don't work that
way like animals and general don't work
that way like you like people have sex
lots of sex and like people don't
respect these sort of arbitrary
boundaries when they're having sex like
whatever genes get might get introduced
into some rich person will either
disappear entirely from the human gene
pool eventually because that's what
happens to
most gene variants or we'll just kind of
diffuse around all over the world after
a while because of just the way that
people have kids together so so you know
I just find some of these science
fiction scenarios that people are
talking about is if they're like real
ethical questions to be silly frankly I
think actually so I'm gonna I'm gonna go
on the other side I think that even if
they're wildly unrealistic and not
mapping out the future I'm glad people
are envisioning the craziest most
extreme scenarios I think will help us
sort of be prepared a little bit for the
brave new world yet to come well but no
but but but but you have to then but
okay you we can talk about these
scenarios but then we have to take the
next step and say like well okay but
here's the basic your the basic facts of
science that tell you that this is not
even something worth considering
you know like for example like I wrote
an article for The Times recently about
studies on DNA and the link between
genes and how long you stay in school
there is a connection there we don't
really know why there's a connection
there and may it may have to do with
genes that influence certain things in
our brains or maybe even our parents
brains we don't know but there's an
association there it's interesting it's
worth studying and you can actually like
look at you know these million variants
in people's DNA and actually come up
with a score a sort of education score
which which sounds very fancy like oh
well I could use that to you know test
some kindergartner and say like you're
never gonna make it to college so we're
just going to put you over here in this
this track and you know you just be
content with your lot and that would be
a ridiculous thing to do because this
score you know it only predicts a small
amount of the variation and how people
do in school so chances are that your
score would be very wrong so there are
lots of people with a high genetic score
who drop out early from school there are
a lot of people with a load
netic score to go into grad school like
it's it's just one variable among
several so you know for people to say
like oh okay well clearly we're gonna
have this future where everybody's fate
is predetermined
well no no and it's not it's not a
scenario worth talking about just
because of the basic statistics of what
we're talking about so yeah you know I'm
all for talking about scenarios but you
have to you have to be willing to throw
some out no I completely agree on that I
mean that that idea that he just said
about sort of predicting people's
educational attainments on base of their
DNA makes you know no sense to me it's
like taking a pre-season Power Poll in
some sports league and then saying well
we don't need to play the games now we
figured out who's going to win but
playing the games actually matters also
so Carl Zimmer or as we say around here
Carl Bildt four-power Zimmer thank you
very much for a wonderful conversations
always great to talk to you
oh it's good talking to you again Sean
all right bye bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]